folks are still trying to wrap their
minds around jada's revelation that she
had a relationship or quote entanglement
with r b singer august alcina while she
and will were secretly separated
the red table talk episode had an
impressive 15 million views
in its first 24 hours on facebook so we
decided to do a little investigating of
our own
you've been on a hell of a journey with
me so what happened jada
july 5th 2015 is when jada first met the
then
22 year old r b singer at one of willow
and jaden's concerts
i was alcina in 2015 in london
and that's where we met he was like man
i could really use some help dealing
with
life nearly five months earlier will and
jada were unleashing some serious red
carpet pda
that look of love that i saw when you
all walked into this carpet my goodness
you know chuck cause there's a gangster
right here in front of y'all
this little one here gangster ride or
die
we now know that behind closed doors
their marriage was on the brink of
collapse
yeah i was done with you
kicked me to the top done with you i
wasn't sure i was ever going to speak to
you again i know i know
we decided that we were going to
separate for a period of time and then
what did you do jada well
you know i think from there
you know as time went on i got into a
different kind of entanglement with
august
an entanglement it was a relationship
absolutely
rumors of a split hit the tabloids i
asked jada about them point blank
on our e.t stage i got to ask you
there's a report coming out that
apparently
you're getting divorced again am i
getting divorced you're getting divorced
and i don't have a ring on oh it must be
true but just so that you know
we're not getting a divorce will told us
a few months later
the marriage had been rocky but they
would never give up
i know you worked hard at marriage you
worked hard at being together
yeah you know our marriage was the most
difficult grueling
and excruciating thing that we've ever
taken on
in our lives and you know we're just
not quitters jada says as she and will
began to rebuild their marriage
august walked away he decided to
break all communication with me right
which was totally understandable
right and i let that be and hadn't
talked to him since
that would mean the relationship could
have been going on when august appeared
on red
table talk in 2018. i was just like
oh something's got to give we can't love
you more than you love yourself
that moment really that was your body
changed the
trajectory of my life three months later
jada told us this
i needed more freedom the public wants
you to be a certain way
your partner needs you to be something
you know i'm really a free spirit at
heart i just felt like
my life had got constricted into this
little box it was
strangling me basically you know 25
years and counting
hmm we ride together we gotta go
together
bad marriage for life
[Music]